(soft electronic music)
- [Astronaut] Where's
the direction-
- [Narrator] As a new frontier
opens in the space market,
(rocket whooshing)
(exciting music)
some companies are trying
to explore the possibilities
of harvesting resources from
the moon and other objects.
Orbiting the earth is a
potential trillion dollar payload
of precious minerals and
fuel sources, companies say,
that could be used to power everyday
electronic devices and cars.
- The moon is
really created from the same materials
that earth is created from.
- It's about exploration,
to gather those minerals,
and bring it back to earth
in a economically-viable way.
- [Narrator] But as
(soft electronic music)
investment in space startups
reaches a record high, some scientists
are skeptical that lunar
mining could become a reality,
questioning the high cost
of space travel,
(astronaut speaking distantly)
and the potential to destroy
valuable geological sites.
One company exploring the possibilities
of extracting the moon's
resources is Astrobotic.
The startup is working with
NASA to develop lunar lander
and rover projects,
(airy music)
which Astrobotic says
could help unlock the moon's
potential in the future.
But those efforts
(soft electronic music)
face mounting challenges
in the coming years.
(room humming)
- Here we go.
- [Narrator] This is
the business of space.
A series focusing on
the innovative startups
(soft electronic music)
capitalizing on the
commercial space industry.
Pittsburgh was nicknamed
"The Steel City" after its
famed manufacturing industry.
(atmosphere humming)
But now, technicians at
Astrobotic want it to be reclaimed
as a space hub.
(soft mysterious music)
And that all starts with
Peregrine, the lander set to travel
to the moon later this year.
- This is the actual flight article,
and we're actually still completing
the propulsion systems integration
from the flight article.
- [Narrator] It's part of
NASA's commercial lunar
payload program.
(airy music)
- That program is designed to contract
with companies like ours to,
again, deliver those payloads
to the surface of the
moon on robotic vehicles.
- [Narrator] It could become
the first American spacecraft
(soft electronic music)
to land on the moon since
the last Apollo mission
more than 50 years ago.
- [Astronaut] It's one small step for man,
(spacecraft humming)
one giant leap for mankind.
- [Narrator] Peregrine
will deliver technologies
to be tested on the moon.
If successful, they may be
used in NASA's Artemis mission.
That's the space agency's plan
to return humans to the moon,
with a view of potential
inhabitation and construction
on the lunar surface,
including the building
of a space camp.
- Where we're at today is
that, we eventually wanna build
the infrastructure and
capabilities to stay on the moon.
And things like building
habitats are dependent on
finding where the
resources are in the moon.
- [Narrator] But some
(soft electronic music)
scientists say that establishing
permanent bases would involve destroying
large quantities of the lunar soil,
which is called regolith,
to make way for buildings.
And that process could destroy
clues as to how the moon,
and by extension, the earth, formed.
- So, just moving
all these terrain can eliminate
that record of the impacts
on the lunar surface that we have.
But also, the upper part of the
lunar soil is like a record of
what happened in the previous
millions years from this, and the sun.
- [Narrator] Companies such as Astrobotic,
and government agencies
like NASA, are interested
in extracting from the regolith
to try and understand
(soft music)
the composition of its resources.
Their aim is to facilitate
continued exploration
and economic development in space.
Scientists have previously
discovered a variety
of minerals and elements on the moon
that could be used to support that goal.
- We can find their
oxygen in high quantities
that will be very helpful
for life support system,
or for propellant and fuel.
We also can find water
ice in the lunar poles,
that also it's very useful
for survival of humans.
We can find other minerals
and other elements
like silicone, metals,
rare earth elements
that we can use to fabricate things
that we need to use there
on the lunar surface.
- [Narrator] But some engineers
are skeptical of the
possibilities of extracting
usable material in
a space environment.
(soft electronic music)
As many technologies are
still in development.
A lunar mining operation
would have to make use
of an unprecedented amount
of innovative tools,
with automated or remote
control machinery,
and pumps that require a
minimal human oversight.
And there are financial
limitations to harvesting
those resources for use on earth.
The cost of fueling trips to
and from the lunar surface
is not currently economically viable,
some researchers say.
Payloads traveling
(soft electronic music)
in the Peregrine lander
can be bought by private
companies, investors,
or government agencies such as NASA.
The U.S. space agency has
commissioned Astrobotic
to work on a series of rovers
as payloads, small robots
that will travel across
the surface of the moon,
and conduct scientific experiments.
One of those being developed
here is the cube rover.
- Cube rovers can be used
for lotsa different missions
and applications.
(cube rover humming)
One of the ones that we're
really excited about here,
is that we have rovers that
can drive several kilometers,
survive lunar nights, using
small platforms that are
orders of magnitude
cheaper than prior rovers
in the past, allows us to scan the surface
of the moon in a much more
affordable and less complex way,
so that we can
(cube rover humming)
understand where the
resources are located.
There's an interesting
phenomenon that happens
with smaller rovers that
we're learning more about
compared to larger rovers,
and that the smaller rovers
actually float on top of the surface.
So, your wheel designs
for these smaller rovers
are likely going to be very different
than some of the larger rovers.
- [Narrator] But there
are lots of challenges
associated with engineering robotics
to work on the lunar surface.
- The lunar surface have
really extreme temperatures,
and really high variation of temperatures.
So that is a challenge for the subsystems
of the rovers and the robotics elements,
but also the terrain.
It has a huge amount of
dust that is really abrasive
and corrosive, and it can
damage the subsystems.
Also radiation, the radiation
can play an impact on the,
especially in the
electronics of the system.
- [Narrator] As many
(soft electronic music)
startups race to capitalize on the moon,
engineers and scientists say there are
limitations and consequences.
One of them is the potential
damage to the environment.
- There are drawbacks to
going to the moon permanently.
Some examples include
leaving our assets behind
on the surface, or
disrupting maybe the far side
of the moon, which is totally
undisturbed right now.
It's looked at as one of the locations
in our solar system where you
could look deep into space,
and have no interruptions,
no noise, background noise
that can influence your observations.
- [Narrator] But given
the environmental costs
of mining the earth, some
say that the moon's resources
could help reduce damage at home.
Companies such as Astrobotic
say those potential benefits
outweigh the risk of disrupting
the moon's natural ecosystem.
- I think that the ability to
harvest resources and use them
to protect our own planet
is incredibly helpful.
- [Narrator] Other scientists
are more skeptical
(soft electronic music)
that the moon could, in
turn, help protect the earth.
But one point they can agree
on, is that establishing bases
on the moon for human visitation
could be decades away.
And harvesting resources
could take even longer.
For now, looking for clues in the regolith
is the first step.